au tour de france et le suisse alex ou
le qui portait le maillot jaune ce matin
au départ de la première étape le suisse
en effet remporté hier le prologue
battant de deux petites secondes le
britannique chris boardman qui l'an
dernier avait été victime d'une grave
chute lors précisément du prologue à
saint brieuc noyés alors sous l'orage
cleeren juillet 1993 dans le tgv qui
l'emmène à paris pour la dernière étape
du tour les gars ligne rennes découvre
dans la presse l'exploit de chris
boardman qui vient de battre le record
de l'heure un exploit tout n'a pas
échappé à l'équipe gan qui s'adjuge des
services de l'anglais le 2 juillet 94
chris boardman prend donc le départ de
son premier tour de france est quel
départ il remporte le prologue en
établissant un record de vitesse encore
inégalé à ce jour mais il abandonne le
peloton au bout de deux semaines le 1er
juillet 95 boardman repart en trombe
sous leur âge de saint brieuc mais son
prologue lamy ne durera que 3 km un
mauvais virage une terrible chute de
fracture birdman rentrer à la maison
mais transcendant la terre est ma
famille première fois dans trois ans je
reste à la maison dans la tête c'est si
c'est bon parce que j'ai le temps pour
chrome plaît aux pensées pour le futur
assassin par l'expert hier goldman
n'était pourtant pas très rassuré
lorsqu'il a pris le départ difficile en
effet de chasser les mauvais souvenirs
lorsqu'on doit à nouveau affronter une
route mouillée de virages serrés mais
cette année il a décidé de terminer le
tour alors il a au trou pour la prudence
ce qui n'a pas empêché de se classer
deuxième de ce prologue ya deux petites
secondes du suisse alex joue le même
lorsqu'il ne prend pas de risque chris
boardman reste vraiment un super membres
du pronom